Carissa another Kings Indian another
Victory with the black pie is a very
important game because tatev was also in
great shape were you surprised when she
played D4 we know she's predominantly a
one E4
player yeah so I think she's only played
like D4 couple times in her life that's
right um so I was definitely surprised
when it was on the board I prepared
mostly for E4 and I had like this brief
leading thought I was like what if she
plays D4 cuz she knows that like you
know I'm always a Kings indan player and
then I was like nah she wouldn't do that
to
me
um but yeah I was surprised and then I
think I was also surprised by this
bishop E2 Bishop E3 line on the board
yep uh I know it's like one of the more
challenging tries but I think like
generally I score well against it um I
don't know if that's true in like my
online database so I was pretty happy
with this I know recently my most recent
game in this land was like KN C6 at the
US junior girls mhm um again soe tang
and then the L time goes like D5
kn5 but I kind of wanted to maybe throw
off her track if she was only prepping
Knight C6 so we went into this uh until
like the usual E5 setup yep with Knight
A6 and
H4 yes and I think I misplayed this here
because usually White's supposed to go
G4 first um but she plays like this set
up with Knight C5 Queen C2 and then yeah
I felt maybe H5 was just best and I was
definitely a bit nervous out here in the
open after like the opening because
there always these ideas of like G4
Bishop G5 which ended up happening in
the game and so I was just hoping that
um before she could kind of have time
for all of that your out on the queen
side yeah and it did it did and I do
believe that at this point instead of uh
G4 which was a mistake Knight to D3 was
the better alternative just to deal with
the Knight on C5 first I have to deal
with the Knight on C5 first and then I
can start thinking about my own attack
on the king side she did not do that
there was a clear difference in
experience between you and her in this
type of positions did you felt the same
way during the game as well did you feel
like you're seeing more you understand
more patterns in these structures in
this
opening yeah definitely which was also
kind of part of why I wasn't really
worried about D4 um because I just felt
if she has less experience in the Kings
Indian then all I have to do is get her
sort of out of theory or out of like her
prep and I should just have a better
understanding of sort of how to play
this and I felt that she didn't really
see like this a for Queen A5 idea umh it
wasn't really something that she was
anticipating yeah so that was just like
one example of how that came to play and
you got to this point and she played
this move Queen to H6 you immediately
blissed out Queen takes C3 your reaction
to uh this queen to H6 and going all
in um I definitely spent a fair bit of
time I think on gtes H sh because Queen
H6 if it works for white I'm just a dead
lost yeah but at that point she was
already a bit low on time I felt so like
my practical ches were good I think also
like I've sort of Consolidated on the
king side because it's really hard for
white to infiltrate with my dark Square
bishop and the queen side's super weak
for what so Queen H6 it kind of felt was
a bit of desperation and I was pretty
sure it wasn't going to work out because
after Rook G1 I have this bishop G4 idea
right mhm Y no CH the game very nicely
calculated after that you finished the
job in style with the last move night to
D3 beautiful game Kissa now you're in
the sole lead at least until the game
between beim and Talia is finished how
are you feeling after round five how are
you feeling about your chances and your
shape as well in this
event um I feel I feel pretty good I
feel that I'm like really
inform this tournament and I'm playing
good chess and hopefully I can sort of
keep that up well congratulations uh
keep it up and we'll see you tomorrow
Karissa indeed our our congratulations
uh as well